hello guys ryan right over here and I'm
Brianna white Briana and I um she's
gonna help me out with something today
she is gonna help me unbox my super geek
box I already forgot the addition and
what month is exactly falls under but
there's a little pamphlet in there that
you've got to find beforehand so you can
tell us what it is uh yeah so please
open the box with this knife thank you
it's Halloween so I figured a knife
would be totally cool sep tember box
okay the theme is unity unity all right
let's get United let's start off all
right big box shirt last all right hurry
for the first thing I'm ready for the
first thing popping of a minion of Dave
that's cool man thank you oh yeah I love
the minions I'll i wish i hope i have a
kid one day that turns out to be a
minyan that would be really depressing
and weird I know but at the same time I
think my opinion would get laid a lot
yeah minion sex right alright cool
Hyrule University Tyrell University oh
that's cool and it's like the color of
the you know here's how it is that the
Triforce on there yeah there's a master
sword wait it's Bob Oh little hybrid
that's pretty cool I'm gonna I have some
everyone I know is really in the Zelda
hey guys it's such a lovable franchise I
gotta I gotta give this away to someone
you should already giving you like two
things yeah I've been yeah you're gonna
fit for someone alright let's see this
thing is is wrapped yes so you get to
unwrap it okay
this is the shirt I'm God oh there's you
sure there's two shirts I know that is
cool Teenage Mutant Ninja squirrels that
is so cool that's pretty cool okay I'm
gonna decide between this shirt and the
next one that's gonna be hard this is
double XL that's big well it's probably
gonna shrink its calm I don't want to
shrink can't let it shirt and don't dry
it alright here's a nice item you ready
yeah the time is upon us make the
plumber pay Oh unity uprising like an
old war propaganda it's like an old war
propaganda podia looks like the
interview that sticker that comes with
oh cool thanks Briana for giving this to
me the time is upon us make the plumber
pay that's pretty cool yeah yeah I I
used to want to be a plumber but you
didn't I did you still want to be a
plumber cuz I thought plumbers got the
most sex why would you think that well
you know they don't call they're like
manly bending over and over there
seducing today grease on their sweaty
and stamping tools wrenches yes that's
my point where you think everyone wanted
to [ __ ] Mario Luigi sex appeal every
woman I know Emily g scream sex appeal
yeah dude Princess Daisy DP what's going
on next one ok we got one little more
item a pin of course go ahead of the
Teenage Mutant Ninja squirtles over here
I don't know if you can see it start
back okay okay there's nothing in here
boy Wow all right next one but to be
fair you did get another shirt another
shirt here we go oh my god okay that's
cool wow that's cool look at that oh man
I don't know oh which
which one should I rock I love this
which one should I wear for the next
video oh my gosh I think you have to do
this one this one it's so hard to
determine but but the Teenage Mutant
Ninja squirtles here thumbnail time hold
it up
wow wow and you know what's funny um I
don't get any of this for free you don't
nope it's not for free I would pay for
this that just seems like it makes so
much sense yeah you should pay for it
and it doesn't benefit me at all if you
buy some he said suspiciously no all
right I am being honest genuine sincere
my real name is ryan right and if you
buy one just for your benefit not mine
there's a link of the description box at
the top that'll you know lead you to
where you can buy water for you and if
you get a super geek box hashtag me in
your post let me know we can be
interactive about oh yeah I got a minion
too that's cool look what there's like
different options on the back do you
think they owe you don't like alternate
i think uh uh yeah i think they only
send Dave I really want the evil minion
I don't know man yell it was cool I mean
being yellow I'm have Chinese blood in
me yes i'm a little yellow it's racist i
know but i can get away with it anyway
guys thanks for tuning in to the Chanel
if you're new to it you can subscribe to
the real rejects Rihanna white funny
this is all gaming related cuz Brianna
white has launched her gaming channel
her her brother called sibling rivalry
check it out what better than watching a
girl with brains play video games right
right is that appropriate what would
have been inappropriate about no yeah
I'm just making sure cuz I know your dad
saw a video recently so i'm trying to
make sure i know your i say something
good about you and it's not perverted
calling me smart is not very perverted
in fact i love that couple the fact that
you know that people actually think a
woman can be smart is kind of perverted
in a way like you know we're doing so
well for a minute there was i I'm just
being honest by a super geek box today